like your kids that go to private or
public I have one kid that goes to
public
Heritage here and I have one that's
online school yeah he was yeah online
yeah what's your thoughts in the public
versus private
and um
Public School you get the diversity you
get everything coming at you the good
the bad the bullies the tough guys the
Geeks it's all just coming at you and
you have a um you have an opportunity to
choose what you're going to do in a
private school
boom everybody's in the same line every
day is the same way no one nobody nobody
gets off the fence we all stay on the
fence in um private school and then
public school on the fence you get off
the fence and you make mistakes
you know most of the private schools
they prevent them the best way possible
we want to make mistakes but the best
way possible they prevent them from
making mistakes and being discouraged
who would who would Mike Tyson have been
if he went to private school
Mike typhen yeah who would he have been
if he would gone to private school
I don't know
not what I am now not what you are now
yeah it wasn't meant for me I would I
probably would uh I probably would have
been snob if I want to pop up you think
so you think that would have been the
case uh I got a little bit of that stuff
in me
I think he brings up a little bit I
think it brings up an amazing point
because I went to public school K
through 10 in my last couple years I I
got a scholarship sports scholarship to
go to private school but I think it was
the public school mentality the bullies
that they don't hang out with that guy
watch your back over here that really
shapes you who you are exactly so I know
that you're a huge advocate for private
school but you're a public school kid
1.8 GPA
what obviously there's so many benefits
going to private school the network the
status the education everything with
that what are the concerns you have with
private school though when you hear
someone like Mike Tyson say yeah it
wouldn't make me the man I am today I've
never gone to private I've gone to
public right so to me when you go to
public you see everything you see gangs
drugs cocaine pot you know the nurse the
athletes the you know these guys those
guys the valedictorian you see it all
there's an advantage to it as well but
my concern is I'm 44 today so I went to
school today your birthday no no I'm 44
years old but uh could you imagine your
birthday is next month all right June
23rd 30th June 30th yeah so I'm a
October 18th baby 1978 so Scorpio over
there I'm Gonna Leave yeah okay your
cancer right yeah yeah cancers are beast
so
um
so 1996 was when I graduated this was
the whole Tupac you know the the only
like the devastating day for me was that
they were in La I'm going to Glendale
High School but
when I was going to High School versus
what I'm seeing today
is not the same like my my high school
today a bunch of people from Glendale
Unified School District have messaging
they've created an Instagram account of
what's going on right now gusd okay how
they're letting uh boys go into girls
bathroom and all this other stuff
it's not the public school we went to
there was none of that when I went to
the girls bathroom I got suspended
now you're being congratulated
which by the way should you be suspended
I think so yeah people can listen I
wasn't gonna know
sexual gratification I was too young I
was going in there to fight the girl she
had to hit me in the face or something
ran in the bathroom yeah Mike said when
he was when he was younger girls bullied
him not guys yeah kicked my ass bit me
at all it's because they liked you
Mike I bet
but your kids being in private school
today well I mean again for me like if
I'm if I'm gonna go on Champions corner
and I want to you know what I want to
learn I want to learn from their
mistakes their wisdom their parents now
they have they have the ability to go
from teens to 20s to 30s to 40s to 50s
there's different desires and
temptations and things that you go
through in every age I want to learn
from it by the way how many people like
if you look at Mike Tyson's life okay
how many people most combined life
experience equals Mike Tyson's hey no
but listen oh man I'm just like you you
don't think I'm scared of those public
schools for my kids because I experience
that stuff you don't think I think I
want somebody to do some lie asking my
kids faith
no but um
if they didn't have that opportunity I
would want them to be in public school
you know we were struggling for the
money to not we want them to go and
experience that you have to expand I
want my kids experience where I lived at
I wanted to take them to Brownfield
Brooklyn let me pizza you know let them
go to the gather them this guy's your
father I love that little kid that's
your father
and wow you did that oh absolutely
what was the reaction when they saw it
scared to death didn't want to get
involved it was the apartment that
pretty condemned but with a hole in in
the uh
the door after myself
[Laughter]
look at this man it's just um a concrete
jungle a concrete jungle and these guys
are um wow these guys are animals
described as human beings
and that's just what it is so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign